vaccine passports from september
nightclubs
we're told on other crowded venues uh
give me more examples
uh well it's a anything that's where
large people get large numbers of people
come together that uh
we we're encouraging to use uh a
certification
uh showing that we want people to do it
voluntarily if it's um
you know big comings together because we
want to stop the spread of the uh
of the the case numbers going up uh
but uh we will be looking at this and
working out how to
operate operationalize it making sure
that people can use it smoothly
but the message is at the moment as also
is
get you back vaccination 85 of adults
have had their first
dose and we're really keen to have that
first that the last 15 percent of people
vaccinated as well
so that we can really come to the end of
of this of this transmission of the
disease yeah my question was give me
more examples sir of of
areas where you will have to have a
vaccine passport
for example will you need to have it to
go to a crowded pub
uh no we we're not saying crowded pubs
at all we're not ruling anything out but
we're not saying crowded pubs we're
saying nightclubs and also large
larger ticketed events uh as well that's
that's that's where we look
some pubs can be as busy as a nightclub
i think this is the difficulty to be
fair and we've got to work on the
definition we've got to define it really
carefully and then we'll do that
that's why i'm asking the coming months
until we get there for that for that
reason
because what we what we're after what
we're after is we're
trying to make sure that i mean even
nightclubs they're very different types
of venues you get some big warehouse
type venues and you get some very small
rooms with a lack of ventilation because
it's all about ventilation and that's
that's what we're
working on but we'll work on that over
the over the next few weeks alongside
nightclub operators i was speaking to
some last week and i know they're
disappointed this morning
clearly because they want us they will
be open last night they
they want to be able to um open and be
able to return to profit
because they've been so hard-pressed but
this is the right thing to do
uh to make sure that we can really get
on top of transmission of cases
so um sporting venues
uh well there are a number of sporting
venues that are already
looking at voluntarily doing this um so
you'll you'll see this come into place
it's really important for my viewers
this morning to know what they can and
can't do
you are representing the government this
morning and you as
a representative of the government are
telling us that we have to
have a vaccine passport from september
but you can't tell me where
for now what i'm saying what i'm saying
to you
is that we are looking at having night
clubs and other
large ticketed events when people are
coming together
this will be in september so we'll work
on the details over the uh
over the next few weeks it's got to go
through parliamentary scrutiny so we've
got to get it absolutely right we've got
to work with the sectors that are going
to be affected
to make sure that we can define this
really carefully all we're doing now is
giving an advanced warning of what is
coming down the line
to make sure that the nhs doesn't get a
swamp to know overbought
uh with with with cases um over the
winter but we'll work on that detail
with the sector and we'll give you
plenty of notice
well they're seen as super spreader
events that according to patrick valance
if they're seen as super spreader events
like nightclubs why are you waiting till
september
because we've got to get the detail
right and what we're trying to do is
get people vaccinated now we're trying
to encourage people as i say
85 percent of adults have had their
first dose 65
have had their both doses we're
encouraging people to get uh
to to to get vaccinated but it's right
that we actually
um stop mandating as much stuff as we
can from the government
and let the economy start to bounce back
but clearly there's still going to be
challenges you don't
this isn't a film that you kill the
baddie you get to the you know the end
of all credits we're still living with
it
a lot to get through so basically what
you're saying is that you're using it as
a bribe to get young kids
to go and get vaccinated ahead of
september
no no no what we're saying is that we we
want to keep people safe we want to stop
the nhs
being overwhelmed by cases throughout
the winter we know that winters
um uh has particular pressures and so
that's the fact that what we have to
face we're still living with kovid
okay are you completely comfortable as a
member of the conservative party
of having what amounts to an id card by
another name
no i'm not comfortable that the
government is mandating anything
uh frankly these you know i'm a very
libertarian uh conservative i want to be
able to back off and that's why
yesterday
was an opportunity for government to
back off from so many different things
and let people live their lives but what
we have to do is make sure that people
can also live their lives
safely the nhs can function safely and
these are the challenges that we still
have to do so
it's incredibly frustrating it's
incredibly complicated to work through
the detail
but that's the challenge we have don't
understand why you're not introducing it
straight away then if it's not a bribe
forget
for young people to uh get vaccinated
why are you waiting until
september i don't get it
because we we we need to look at um as i
say the detail behind it as well to make
sure that um
nightclub operators and other event
operators actually work at work work
can know how to operationalize the
detail to be able to
work it through on the door we've got to
get the technology right as well and
we've got to
we've got to make sure people can you
know fully understand what's coming but
in the meantime we're
encouraging people to use it and
operators to use it voluntarily and i
hope that some night club operators and
event operators
will be using it voluntarily to keep
people safe within their venues
you've had 18 months these nightclubs
have been shot for 18 months why didn't
you do it before now
what 18 months ago we uh we didn't even
know what we were facing so
i'm not sure we've had 18 months to do
it because we've only just really worked
through this
spread or the aerosols that were there
what we've been encouraging nightclubs
to do
is and i know loads of nightclub
operators already do this is make sure
that they're increasing their um
air changes in their venues because it's
so much of it it's about ventilation
and as i said you've got a lot of
different types of operators a lot of
different types of venues so when you're
trying to bring something in
that can actually work with uh
hospitality venues across the board
then it's it it is difficult and it is
frustrating around the edges for
something
operated okay so there's lots more to
talk about with that in the coming days
and weeks
um talk to me about the i think we've
got an image of the
front cover of your manifesto the tory
manifesto for the last election
the first page saying that there'll be
no rise in national
insurance and there it is circled for
you right there no rise in national
insurance that was a pledge
from boris johnson he signed it at the
bottom um
are you increasing national insurance
well i i've read about the speculation
this morning that's not something i
recognize so
um you know we'll see what happens in
terms of the uh
when we announce our details on social
care but uh which is what i think you're
talking about but uh that's not
something i recognize
so how would you feel given that it was
a pledge from the prime minister
if there was an increase in national
insurance how should my viewers feel
this morning about that
well what what i think your viewers will
want is a solution for social care and i
think that's why
they'll want you to do it they elected
you on your manifesto
and you're going back on your manifesto
pledge if you put up national insurance
so what i'm saying is how do you feel
that they would feel about that if you
did
once we found okay i'm not going to get
involved in speculation on a newspaper
report it's not something i recognize
but what we do want it to happen
is to make sure that we can come up with
a comprehensive approach program to
tackle social care it's been around
for a long time this issue we really do
need to get to grips with it and that's
what the prime minister and the health
secretary are really determined to do
okay what's this um that i'm reading
about your boss saying he didn't believe
the nhs would uh
be overwhelmed during the pandemic last
year if you did say that
and if you did think that why did you
spend half a billion pounds on
nightingale hospitals
we i'm assuming you're talking about the
interviews with dominic cummings which
is
something that will come out later i
mean look we we were in this situation
over the last 18 months when we've been
uh living with covid we've been learning
about kobe as
has happened over the global pandemic
there are plenty of things that we've
done
uh to to prepare some of which we needed
uh to
the nth degree some of which we didn't
need as much the nightingale hospitals
were absolutely played a pivotal role if
you speak to anybody
that was working in those nightingale
hospitals the stuff that they saw the
stuff they had to deal with was
was horrific um and uh and so
it was right that we actually set up a
lot to tackle something we really didn't
know what we were facing
um the one in london was hardly used
but nonetheless the the the people that
were there were actually as i say
pretty um uh in horrendous condition and
so
you know i haven't spoken to the the guy
in my local hospital to help set it up
um you know firsthand experience of a
firsthand uh story of the sort of
what he had to face and it it wasn't
pretty
and that wasn't a nightingale hospital
though was it not that wasn't a
nightingale hospital that you're talking
about there was it
yes it was no it was it was the
nightingale it was the original
nightingale hospital in the excel center
so okay so it was worth the half a
billion pounds that was spent on the
nightingale hospitals despite your boss
saying
that the nhs would not be overwhelmed
we've
we've we've spent 407 billion pounds
trying to get the
economy safe trying to save people's
lives trying to make sure that we could
uh keep the pressure as best we could
off the nhs
some of which um were we could have
needed more some of which we
you know we may well have overspent
because we could in in terms of the fact
that uh
we didn't know what we were facing it
was right that we keep people safe
that's the
that's the first rule of any government
keep um
keep people safe and that's what we've
been trying to do that's what we'll
continue to do
okay um is spain going to be added to
the amber watch list
those sort of decisions are taken um at
cabinet level they'll they'll
they'll look at the data and they'll
make sure that they can
work out what what it what is best to
make sure that
we keep transmission of the virus low we
keep the transmission of the variance
low
because it's the variants that are
really key here to work out how they how
they're
interacting with our with our vaccine
program a lot of people
who've gone on holiday to spain will be
watching us this morning in their hotel
rooms before they go out for the day
he's talking about the data um the
numbers
uh in mainland uh france
were three times lower than what they
are
in spain at the moment so does that mean
that you're going to put them on the
list
or or not i mean they'll they'll want to
know whether they need to book a flight
yeah it's not just about we try and give
people as much notice as we can okay but
it's not just about
the pure numbers it's also about the the
variance and the style of variance the
beta variant for example
that's um that's uh quite prevalent in
france at the moment uh we're looking
about how that interacts with the
astrazeneca vaccine and so there's a lot
of factors that involved
in in the decisions that are taken
around travel
comes back to the point i was saying
earlier we've got to keep people safe
and we've got to make sure that we can
keep on top of carrying on with travel
carrying on with travel um the us
has put us the uk on the highest risk
level do you think that's fair
well again they were to take their
decisions i'm not going to comment on
their decisions i think what you know
what we've got to do is look at
and have discussions with with the us
and other countries to make sure that we
can
keep as much open as possible because
we've talked a lot about the uk
but you're right to look at travel not
just for holidays although it's
hugely important this time of year but
to make sure that we can remain
connected
that's good for the economy it's good
for actually getting that money in for
the through the treasury
to cover the costs of the things that
we've just been talking about
okay a final thought before i let you go
cinderella um
has been um canned at least for now when
will lord lloyd webber be able to open
his uh new production
well there's some uh productions that
are opening this week i i know that but
i know how frustrating it is because
with people getting pinged and this is
why we're trying to work through this
we're trying to uh
to to make sure that we can keep people
safe but also uh
make sure people can get back to work i
know really how frustrating it is
because i'm the minister for london as
well and i want to see
london back as a vibrant uh community a
vibrant global city
okay did you wear your mask at the
evening standard party last night
i wore my mask going in and out but uh
but but not in the party itself